we've considered arithmetic sums where
each term is a fixed amount larger than
the previous term by an additive amount
another kind of sum called geometric
sums which we're going to look at now
come about where each sum is a fixed
multiple of the previous sum and these
come up all the time lots of different
settings in this particular case we're
going to look an example of how it
applies to analyzing the value of money
in the future so let's begin with a
geometric sum and there's the standard
form of it geometric sum is of the form
1 plus X plus x squared up through the
nth power of X and for uniformity notice
that 1 is actually X to the 0 so we're
taking the sum from any K equals 0 to n
of X to the K now what I'd like to do is
find a nice closed form for this without
those ellipses and and having a growing
number of terms N and there's a simple
trick with the arithmetic sum the way
Gauss got it and the way we got it was
by reversing the summon aiding the
things together this time the trick is
to multiply G n by X now what's that
going to do is it's going to increase
the power of X in each term by 1 which
is tantamount to a right shift let's
look at that there's X G of n so 1 times
X course I'm subtracting looking ahead
so 1 times X is minus L minus X 1 X
times X is x squared I'm going to such
as subtract it down through X to the N
minus 1 times X gives me the X to the N
term and finally I have an extra term
from right shifting X to the N to be X
to the n plus 1 now let's do this
subtraction but of course I'm gonna line
the terms up so that they're easy to
subtract and now all the terms in the
middle cancel which is very cool because
we've just figured out that GN minus x
GN is 1 minus X to the n plus 1 so we
have this nice elegant formula now I can
factor out GN and I get a GN times 1
minus X on the left and the result is
that I get the GN is 1 minus X to the n
plus 1 over 1 minus
X this is actually a formula that we
proved before by induction but when we
did it by induction there was no clue
about who was the clever person to think
of this formula now you know how that
clever person found it and that's as
kind of a standard trick that we'll see
more of when we look at generating
functions but for now it's a simple
trick for getting a nice closed form for
a sum we refer to as the perturbation
method you take the sum you perturb it a
little see how it relates to itself get
an arithmetic relation and solve for a
formula for the sum okay a geometric
series I use the word sum for a finite
sum geometric series is when you take an
infinite sum so the infinite geometric
sum is the sum 1 plus X plus x squared X
to the N and it keeps going it's the sum
from I equals 0 to infinity of X to the
I and there's a simple formula for that
too it's even simpler actually because
the definition of an infinite sum is
it's the limit of the truncated songs
it's the limit of the sum of the first n
terms as n goes to infinity
assuming that limit exists and so for
the value of this infinite series is the
limit of GN which is the sum up to n and
let's look at that well it's what it's
GN is 1 minus X to the n plus 1 over 1
minus X so the limit of that the limits
distribute pass the 1 down to and the X
doesn't have an N in it so it winds up
being 1 minus the limit as n approaches
infinity of X to the n plus 1 divided by
1 minus X and as long as X is less than
1 X to the n plus 1 is going to go to 0
and I wind up with this nice simple
formula that the infinite series the sum
from I equals 0 to infinity of X to the
I is equal to 1 over 1 minus X providing
that the magnitude of X is less than 1
okay
that's the basics mathematical
preliminaries of of geometric sums and
geometric series now let's look at a
typical application having to do with
the future value of money
suppose we want to make the following
deal I promise I will pay you $100 in
one year if you will pay me a fixed
amount now so let's call it X dollars
and the puzzle is how much money is $100
worth if you can't have it now you can
only have it in one year it's worth X
dollars how we gonna figure out what X
should be what would be a fair amount
for you to pay me so that I'm willing to
pay you $100 in one year and it's fair
nobody loses okay well here's the basic
fact that is the basis for evaluating
what the value of money in the future is
is I'm going to assume that my bank will
pay me three percent interest this is a
generous Bank in today's economy but it
used to be a stingy offer interest rates
in my lifetime have ranged between about
17 percent a year down to less than one
percent a year three percents a
reasonable number to play with so let's
suppose that my bank commits to paying
me three percent interest on a deposit
now that is to say let's define the bank
rate beat to be 1.03 and the deal is
that the bank will increase the money
that I have now by a factor of B in one
year okay
well so if I deposit your X dollars now
I means I will have B times X dollars in
one year okay assuming that the bank is
completely reliable there's no risk
there and it's and I get exactly B times
X in one year then I won't lose any
money providing that B times X is
greater or equal to 100 I need the X
dollars you give me now to be worth the
hundred dollars I'm supposed to pay you
I'll come out ahead if B X is greater or
equal to 100 I'll lose if it's less than
100 and it's a completely fair if B X is
equal to 100 all right well that means
that X is simply 100 over B which we
decided was 1.0 three ninety seven oh
nine so a hundred dollars in one year is
worth ninety seven dollars and nine
cents or normalizing to one dollar one
dollar in one year is worth ninety seven
since essentially now well now we can
shift perspective a little bit and think
back a year so how much money did I need
last year in order to be worth a dollar
today well by the same reasoning the
bank is gonna pay me B times R today so
I need B times R to equal a dollar in
other words I R has got to be 1 over B R
is 1 over the bank rate so a dollar a
year ago is worth our dollars a year ago
is worth a dollar today and by the same
reasoning n dollars paid in two years is
worth end-times are paid in one year
which is worth n times R squared paid to
debt paid today so I can iterate this
bank of this one over bank rate factor
and as time goes on a K years out a
value of n dollars paid in K years is
worth any times R to the K today where R
is 1 over the bank rate okay that's good
to know
let's think about annuities now an
annuity is a contract that people buy to
provide income for themselves without
risk so they will make a deal typically
with insurance company where they will
pay a certain amount of money now to the
insurance company and the insurance
company promises to provide them a
regular income sometimes for life or
sometimes for a fixed period so let's
look at an example I will pay you $100 a
year for 10 years if you will pay me a
fixed premium what should it be
so I'm gonna promise as the insurance
company to pay you $100 a year for 10
years I want you to pay me a premium of
Y dollars now how much should you pay
well let's think about it
um $100 in one year is worth a hundred
times R and $100 in two years is worth
100 times R squared and finally $100 in
10 years is worth 100 times R to the
10th so this is the amount that I will
have to pay you in today's dollars I
need in or
be paying you a hundred dollars a year
for ten years I need a total of this
mount much amount of money now because
each of these terms is the amount of
money that the hundred dollars will be
worth paid to you that many years out
well look at this sum if i factor out a
hundred are I'm left with a hundred are
times the geometric sum from 1 to R to
the ninth where the base of the sums are
the factor is r well we can have a nice
formula for that it's simply 1 minus R
to the 10th over 1 minus R and now
plugging in R equals 1 over 1.03 I wind
up with the conclusion that this annuity
is worth eight hundred and fifty three
dollars and two cents today my promise
to pay you a thousand dollars but spread
out over the next 11 years is worth
eight hundred and fifty three dollars
and two cents today assuming that the
bank rate is 3% a year and that's a
typical case where a geometric series
come up and you'll see other examples in
problems just a quick thing to think
about
suppose that the bank rates rapidly
increase unexpectedly increase the Fed
finally gets the economy moving and
interest rates run up to 5% say what
happens on this annuity you've already
paid me the eight fifty three and I've
already committed to paying you a
hundred dollars a year for the next ten
years starting in a year who comes out
ahead if bank if Bank rates increase you
come out ahead the deal stays fair or I
come out ahead and I'll close by letting
you think about that question